I'm about to experience weightlessness
for the first time oh my god oh my god
that is so strange this is totally
freaky this is way better than I
expected
I'm just gonna say this right now I'm
going up to the ceiling and here we are
I am a ridiculously excited because
behind me is a zero g plane I'm in
France I was invited here by the
youtuber Bruce this is Bruce dianna
physics girl we are going flying some
parameters we're going into zero-g it's
gonna be awesome come on the principle
behind weightlessness is pretty simple
the plane and everything inside it just
need to accelerate towards the earth at
the same rate as a freely falling object
in a vacuum that is 9.8 meters per
second squared so you can think of your
body as this pen and the plane as this
bottle and when it's freely falling
there's no contact force between the pen
and the bottle and so the pen feels
weightless so you might think the way to
do this is just to put the plane into a
dive but that's not actually how it
works
instead the plane starts climbing at a
steadily increasing angle with no
windows inside it's impossible to tell
that this is happening and all you feel
is pressed into the floor with a force
1.8 times your body weight this is
because the planes acceleration is
directed upwards and perpendicular to
the floor and it makes standing very
difficult not only are you nearly twice
as heavy all the blood drains from your
head and into your feet which made me
pretty dizzy
so weak lying on your back is much more
comfortable and we're advised not to
move our heads around and look straight
ahead
because in hyper G our vestibular system
is hypersensitive to movement which can
lead to motion sickness and that's why
this is sometimes called the vomit comet
once the plane is climbing at about 50
degrees
the engines are ramped down and the
plane is put into a parabolic trajectory
it's at this point that you start
experiencing weightlessness I can feel
myself getting lighter whoa that is such
a strange feeling that is so weird the
plane and you are still moving upward
but you are accelerating downward then
the plane Peaks and start speeding up
again towards the Earth the whole time
the plane is accelerating toward Earth
with the same acceleration as a
free-falling object in vacuum the pilots
have to very skillfully adjust the
thrust to perfectly balance air
resistance and maintain exactly this
acceleration okay oh my goodness how do
you feel so it's like touring this
bottle into the air the Penan side
experiences weightlessness from the time
it leaves my hand until it comes into
contact again after 22 seconds of
weightlessness the pilots pull out of
the dive again subjecting us to hyper G
as the plane accelerates upwards in
total what we performed 13 of these
zero-g parabolas plus one Martian
gravity and two moon gravity parabolas
okay we are now in Mars gravity in Mars
gravity I can do one-arm pull-ups maybe
I am the Martian we brought along some
experiments to do in zero-g
this is in about 1g of gravity this is
what the flame looks like on this
barbeque later now we're gonna try it in
hyper gog and then we'll try it in
zero-g and it should be we take it for
granted that flames have this
distinctive shape but that's only
because of gravity the products of
combustion have more energy and so move
around faster and take up more space
than the cooler air around them
therefore there's a buoyant force on
them which is greater than their weight
and so hot air rises this helps pull in
the oxygen from around the flame to
continue the reaction I keep blowing out
the candle because the stress of hyper G
is significant in hyper G this effect is
magnified since the effective gravity is
almost twice as much this amplifies the
difference between the weight of the hot
air and the weight of the cooler air
around it when so the hot air rises
faster making a longer flame
[Music]
oh my goodness look at that flame just
wafts and zero-g because there's much
less buoyant for us to carry away and so
the combustion is not as good you can
see a lot of smoke coming off of that
candle that is incredible hey so we
still have the guest flue so this is why
the flame is not circular in zero-g the
hot air is still less dense than the
cooler air but now there is no weight
and no buoyant force so the flame
doesn't rise as high this flame still
maintains some of its shape because of
the flow of fuel from the lighter
otherwise the flame would form a sphere
like on the space station where it's
very difficult to maintain the
combustion reaction because it's hard
for oxygen to access the fuel with all
of the combustion products getting the
way so if you're ever unsure about what
the gravitational acceleration is where
you are well looking at a flame is a
pretty good way of finding out
I also brought along a slinky to try the
slow motion slinky drop but in zero-g of
course here I couldn't dangle the slinky
under its own weight so I swung it
around my head instead the effect should
be similar with each coil stretch to
provide the tension that keeps the
length of slinky beyond that
accelerating in uniform circular motion
I wanted to see what happens to the end
of the slinky when I let go here we go
three two one
did you catch that the slinky remained
fairly stretched out and kept rotating
at about the same frequency as before
initially I thought this was a boring
result but then I realized the reason
the slinky doesn't contract is because
weight was never part of this equation
the slinky stretched out in the first
place because it was rotating and since
it's rotating after I let go roughly the
same amount of tension is required to
maintain that circular motion and so it
doesn't contract in zero-g it's possible
to have a stretched slinky rotating in
place without contracting as long as the
tension in the slinky provides the
centripetal force it'll keep spinning
this just goes against my intuition
which is made of course only out of
experiences with gravity being
weightless was an unforgettable
experience
but maybe my favorite part who is how it
challenged my intuition and that's the
reason we need to do research in zero-g
I want to say a huge thanks to the team
at Nova spaz who made this an
unforgettable experience and of course
to Bruce who runs the French YouTube
channel equals safe for inviting me you
should really go check out his video
from the zero-g experience and of course
Diana the physics girl go check out her
video on zero-g here